[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 152 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
my name is Mark Mandal and as always i'm
here with my colleague melanie warwick
8ohm oh hi we're in the same room we are
in the same room I don't know when's the
last time we were actually it was pretty
excited this week you're bringing yet
another one of your amazing episodes or
interviews that you had while you were
in Africa I am this is our last
interview actually that we captured
while I was over in Cape Town
specifically stellenbosch at the deep
learning in Java and we specifically met
with cream and muthoni who both are out
of inste deep and they talked to us a
little bit about their corporation as
well as you know just in general AI
corporations Out of Africa and
communities that are being built cuz
muthoni in particular has a community
that she's established out of nairobi so
we get into that which will be great but
as always we start out with their cool
things of the week and we're gonna end
with our question of the week and the
question which is coming all the way
from mark which is if I want to create a
gke cluster with a specific major
kubernetes version or even just the
latest using the command line tool so
how do I do that how do you do that you
can tell me how we do that
alright so cool things of the week we're
gonna kick it off with an article we
both found and this was actually mark
found and this is this article that's
titled is there life on other planets
Google Cloud is working with NASA's
frontier development lab to find out so
it's really interesting actually it
talks a little bit about these two
approaches that they've broken down into
researching the biology's of distant
planets and one approaches in particular
their modeling the possible atmospheres
that could exist on distant planets and
they analyzed more than like 270,000
simulated atmospheres on compute engine
and this modeling that they did they
actually have code that they've shared
on github it's called PI Atmos and
there's a link in the blog post that you
can check out and then the second
approach is that they're then generating
an actual spectral data set of over 3
million rocky terrestrial exoplanets
with machine learning so we're good
apparently we don't have enough data yet
but we have a ton of visual images that
have been captured by different
satellites that exist and then they've
done a
can amount of simulating as well to try
to help come up with good models to
identify rocky terrains that would
potentially have life so that data set
they're planning to release sometime in
the near future and you can keep an eye
out for it but you should check this
blog out it's interesting and nice
hearing about what's going on in that
space and how machine learning
technology is playing a role
yes yeah cool mm I agree next the cool
thing the way combines actually both of
us games and AI which i think is really
cool special in a special one of the
community members and I I'm gonna
apologize I'm gonna mess up your name
I'm gonna assume it's Jim Aparo I know
that's probably close it's good job I'm
gonna be that they are data scientist
they've been doing amazing stuff with a
Starcraft 2 learning environment project
so if you're not familiar with that
that's a project that comes out of
deepmind
Pi site 2 is deep mines Python component
of the Starcraft 2 loading environment
basically it exposes Blizzard
Entertainment's Starcraft 2 s machine
learning API as a Python environment
basically you can build intelligent
agents that play Starcraft 2 which is
kind of Awesome it's all part of this
effort that's going on right now like
deep mines had worked on alphago and is
you know that's part of their space
dota2 out of open AI exploring
reinforcement learning algorithms and
the machine learning space to be able to
play these games and have the machines
play these better than humans in essence
but this is a place you can experiment
with and tools you can experiment with
so yeah the cool thing of the week is
not just that because that is cool but
the thing that gem is actually done is
if you listening to this and you're like
that sounds great I want to play with it
they wrote a code lab that you can go
through to learn about the environment
how to set it up how to get it going and
basically start building and running
your own agents which is super cool yeah
it's really cool as well in that well
you do need Starcraft the game but you
don't need a license to actually set it
up and run it which is really nice I
like how I'm able to get you over to the
machine learning side with the games
another cool thing of the week we want
to mention is there's an additional
module that has been added to the
machine learning crash course that's out
there I mean this module in particular
is focused on fairness and machine
learning so you should check this out if
you have any interest in this this I
brought this up I know a lot this year
and we did a podcast a while back about
machine learning bias and fairness and
so this is a nice module that helps you
explore that looking at different types
of human biases that
to manifest in training data and you
know it helps provide strategies to
identify them and evaluate their effects
so you can see that in the machine
learning crash course check it out yes
awesome we have one of our wonderful
developer advocate teammates martin
omander they have written a serverless
from the ground up building a simple
micro service with cloud functions this
is part one apparently they take a sort
of real-world approach and coming up
with a company that needs to do a
certain thing in this case listing and
viewing Docs and then taking that and
saying okay how can we do that with
cloud functions what would that flow
look like how would that work with like
say in between like talking to different
teammates and how they would work
together on this it's actually a really
nice step-by-step instructional on how
to build up these sort of micro services
and also last thing the cool thing of
the week is that while I was at deep
learning in Java I met Emily Muller and
rabona murabba who are building out
their own podcast called superposition
OCO and they did this recording with the
Mojo Miller and Nando de Freitas who
talked about machine learning talked
about the conference it's a great
podcast and a great video that they
included so we're gonna include a link
and give them a shout out in our podcast
for this week ultimately yeah seems
appropriate considering we're also
talking about deep learning this week
all right mark I think it's time for us
to get into our interview let's go do it
on today's podcast I'm excited that
Kareem gear and muthoni won yo ek are
both joining me to talk about it's a
deep and building communities in Africa
so thank you both for joining thank you
thank you we are actually recording this
as is another one of our podcasts that
we're currently recording out of the
deep boning in dawa which is currently
happening in Stellenbosch south africa
so let me go ahead and get started like
we usually do which is cream can you
tell us a little bit about yourself
sure so I'm half Tunisian half French
actually grew up in a small city you
know close to the Sahara called the
Tatooine light the Sun planet in star
wars literally I grew up through
learning progressively made my way to
graduate to a Cal Poly technique in
France and ultimately the u.s. where I
was at the Courant Institute at New York
University and through the process I
always had this idea to give back come
back to Africa at some point to do
think interesting and useful and this
has guided my choices and to what is
today instead of nice Tony tell us a
little bit about you yeah thank you I
grew up in a small town in Kenya called
and after that went to school in URI and
then started working in the city Nairobi
I work at instead deep I lead the team
in Nairobi as well as a strategy of
expanding into Africa and building
talent across Africa yeah
nice okay so as I mentioned this is
being currently recorded at the deep
learning and dub I know we're not going
to be releasing exactly at the same time
but what has been really valuable
experiences for you from this conference
so far I think I mean the level of
enthusiasm is fantastic the quality of
the speakers is really top-notch I like
to see this as a nips you know the same
quality and speakers that you would have
at nips except that nips has 5,000 or
6,000 attendees and here it's a much
smaller audience so I think it's an
exceptional opportunity to really build
AI communities in Africa and we should
be very thankful to the deep learning in
dhaba team for what they are doing and
the changes they're making on the ground
nice and muthoni what are some of the
valuable experiences for you for me I
think having been part of planning the
in dhaba this year the main takeaway for
me has just been to see all the people
that we've been communicating with for
many months come together and to also
see the quality of research that is
coming out of Africa and very
interesting posters are being presented
every day as well as very interesting
sessions for example to build on machine
learning skills or how to write good
paper skills and that kind of experience
has been really good nice muthoni I know
you are involved with actually putting
together this conference how did you get
involved it's a very interesting story
so my colleague Mike organized of the
community narrow we came to the endeavor
last year and the planning committee had
really decided that they wanted to host
the in debye in Kenya in 2019 when she
came to me and share
the vision of the India which is to
strengthen the participation of Africans
in machine learning I was sold
immediately because it's what we do with
a community in Nairobi so then we had a
chat with Shakira and the rest of the
team we seem to like each other and we
started the process of planning in dhaba
this year and the rest is history
yes yes and we'll be hosting a thousand
people next year so that should be
exciting it's really exciting yeah on
Krim you're here this year because
you're speaking can you tell us a little
bit about what you're talking about yeah
so my sessions gonna be on Thursday
about the life of a machine learning
startup and the goal is really to give
some insights about what it takes to
build a startup but specifically a
machine learning startup and
specifically in Africa so looking
forward to share some knowledge and also
raise the awareness in the community
about the opportunities that there are
for AI in Africa what are some of the
opportunities I think we have tremendous
talent and one of the insights that I
want to convey is that in today's world
it's actually possible to build a high
quality machine learning startup in
Africa all the sources of knowledge are
there the sources of mentoring
high-quality mentoring er then are with
events such as deep learning in dhaba so
really make the new generation aware of
what's possible and share some of the
enthusiasm and some of the experience
that we've been through at instead of
tell us a little bit about what in
Siddiq does how it started so instead of
is an AI startup that's an African AI
startup which bridges the gap between
advanced AI research and large companies
that have really needs real business
needs so the way we've done that is by
developing our own research but being
able to explain and convey to the
communities to the companies how
advanced AI can benefit to them so that
is that has been you know or our
experience and what we've discovered by
doing that also the project started in
North Africa in Tunisia started as a
bootstrap literally Mike of
Zhora and i started with two laptops and
a lot of enthusiasm and what we've
discovered is that it's actually
possible to bring a promising African
talent to competitive levels in AI to be
able to add real values to companies in
Africa and beyond that's the main
takeaway and that's also my main message
we have to be optimistic about AI in
Africa the opportunity is tremendous and
you know I think this is our agenda all
here to convey that message and make
sure it's widely spread definitely not a
hidden agenda for sure well in terms of
Institue when we were talking offline
you were telling me that it's in five
different locations exactly were those
locations so we started initially in
Tunis in Africa now we have three
locations were operational in Kenya
that's the team that Buitoni leads we
are also rational in Lagos Nigeria and
we also have offices in Paris and London
so five locations and looking forward to
continue to expand our presence in
Africa nice and muthoni how did you get
involved through my community work
Karim had visited Nairobi because he's a
Google launched but accelerator mentor
so Nairobi is quite the city and you
just fall in love immediately so he was
interested in setting up in Nairobi and
was meeting with people within the
community so that's how I met with Karen
and was sold on his vision of growing AI
in Africa and providing opportunities
for brilliant people to work on exciting
projects and the group in terms of you
mentioned about the Google Launchpad
accelerator I know you're also a GTE you
Google developer expert just I also know
we talked about this that you're using
Google Club products as well what are
some of the products that you're
currently using identity tensor flow is
our main platform in AI it's a
tremendously powerful tool I think
people do not realize how powerful this
tool is and we're really grateful to
have that free access that Google has
provided so in my experience as also an
MLG D I've come to appreciate all the
work that Google is doing particularly
for example
such as the assistant are tremendously
powerful and make advanced AI available
to all startups and mention another one
which i think is extremely impressive
she's Auto machine learning Auto ml that
is a groundbreaking product it
effectively enables startups all over
the world and including in Africa to
have access to high-quality AI without
needing extended teams so participating
to you know Launchpad accelerator Africa
with Google be helping build a ecosystem
has been also a tremendous opportunity
for me to meet great people and it's
through those channels that I have come
to meet with mutiny and also being
convinced that now is the time to make a
difference on the ground in Africa so it
has encouraged me and acted as a
catalyst to the vision I initially had
thanks and you were mentioning about
communities muthoni I do want to talk a
little bit about their security and
particularly that you run which is the
Nairobi women and machine learning how
did you get involved with that community
the community with Kathleen two years
ago I had just graduated for my
undergrad and was walking in government
like any open data initiative and
there's a lot of buzzwords around big
data
yeah and all that and there's a lot of
expectations in our scope of work so we
were learning a lot of new skills but I
felt the need to connect with people who
are working in a similar space so we can
share ideas or resources or just know
what is happening around the world
together so that's how I launched about
the women in machine learning and data
science community and reached out to
them and they were happy to help us get
set up in Nairobi and then after that we
did a call for volunteers who are
interested in helping build a community
so two years later we run a lot of
workshops from introductory classes on
how to use Python and our to more
advanced classes on tensorflow and
advanced AI concepts and it's very
interesting the range of people
attending the lessons for example we
have university lecturers coming to
Python or satiny old gal coming to learn
how to program so it's been a very
interesting experience building that
community never became how large is the
community right now we have close to
1,800 people on Meetup
we probably have met 700 of people so
it's a huge group and how we run things
is that it's very volunteer led so a lot
of people will come to us and then see I
need in the community and we let them
champion that as a project within the
community it's one interesting one that
I would mention is we did a masterclass
celebrating the International Women's in
March we did a master class introduction
in Python and our and the ladies
attending were very very interested in
it and two of them volunteered to grow
that class and now they are doing a
course across four months and have a
class of about thirty ladies in Nairobi
and in Kenya doing the course by
themselves remotely and then giving
feedback every week and results and
sharing knowledge and skills what did I
use to help work remotely together they
use slack so the coordinate class on
slack we took the hour for data science
walk book by Hadley Wickham and then
divided that across and made that a
curriculum spread out over four months
and then we use slack to coordinate work
as well as github because a lot of the
people also were not using github and
that really counts when you're for
example applying for a job so now they
can upload their projects there and I
able to showcase their work when dealing
with recruiters for example and now I've
pretty impressed at how important github
has become in the space and when I talk
to people and I tell them all the time
and even here I was talking to people
about how important it is to publish on
github yeah to not wait for it to be
perfect yeah just get it out there you
show that you're working on something
yeah well so do you collaborate with
other women in machine learning
communities or other communities in
Nairobi or outside of Nairobi we do so
for example just out of us having the
community Nairobi now we have a
community in Lagos of women in machine
we also have walk with the few women
taking the data science class in Uganda
and just a day in dhaba I've met very
many ladies who are very excited to have
similar communities in their countries
so very very exciting times for building
the skills of women in Africa for
machine learning yes
it sounded like you said it was I made
up some people want to explore or check
out the group that's where they can find
it yeah Oh cream what is community I
mean we talked a little bit already
about this but what does that mean to
you in terms of these types of
communities and you know your company
and the interest that you have in AI so
I think it's very important to help
communities understand the opportunity
so a lot of what we do is actually
trying to bring that NoHo and helping
people like focus on what really matters
I would say today the problem is not the
lack of information it's maybe like
another information overflow so a big
part of what I do as a mentor and we
also organize tensorflow meetups very
active we organize a hackathon a month
ago I was in Legos organizing a
hackathon I was really impressed by the
talent and the passion of the young
students and engineers there so a big
part of what we do is raise awareness
break a sort of mental idea that oh you
cannot be world class in Africa you
actually as an African highest atop you
can compete with the best and we had
like really very constructive exchanges
here at deep learning in DuBois with you
know Nando Freitas and David silver from
deep mind and the feedback was really
very positive and this encouraged us to
continue to share the message all
through Africa that AI is a real
opportunity that you can be world-class
in AI all what it takes is positivity
willingness to learn energy and I
believe in the continent we have a lot
of that in any advice or recommendations
for those companies that are considering
looking at you know we're having their
own offices in parts of Africa I think
the key thing in the eye and in many
other things is focusing on the people
so for example at insa deep we
do not have a specific plan that we
should be for example like having an
office in a particular country or city
it is really driven by the quality of
the people when we feel we have the
right partners and we're so excited to
have mattoni in Kenya we have a great
machine learning team also in Nigeria so
when you have the right team the right
people you can build and that's my main
message analysis I think it's
particularly relevant in Africa it's
about investing on the right people who
share your vision who share your
enthusiasm so my message to companies
looking potentially at you know hiring
African talent is try to look actively
for the top talent and most importantly
for the people who have a willingness to
learn a willingness to challenge
themselves to get to a certain level of
competitiveness and collaboration within
the teams so I've been really surprised
by how quickly we've met some of the
right people and at the end of the day
and a I or anything else it's people
driven very much so I agree and
appreciate that too from the standpoint
of you know talking about the community
building talking about the corporation
you know having that opportunity to
explore these communities and see where
the talent is and then also giving back
and giving back in terms of the training
is phenomenal I know we talked about
this earlier already you were touching
on some of the tools that are being used
you know when you bring in your talent
it sounds like you're doing some of your
own training as well and helping people
grow is that correct yes absolutely yeah
and so what are some of the key skills
in particular that you're trying to
build out so and we believe that it's
possible to take motivated and young
student or engineer let's say undergrad
or you know completing the grad studies
and get them very quickly to onto
working on AI research problems which
you know would be considered like PhD
plus I think that's been one of the you
know fascinating surprises I've had you
know building the company is to see that
this is actually possible we had great
success stories some you know fantastic
women students we had on the team you
know instead he really believes in
diversity and making sure everybody has
an equal opportunity and we've been
really surprised by
stories we've had interns push the
state-of-the-art of work that's been
done in Silicon Valley so this is I
believe an exciting time and the key
message I want to convey is do not
believe the opportunity is something
removed from you if you are truly
motivated if you truly want to learn
there is a way and there are mentors
available to help whether me or all the
amazing people are deep learning
endeavor to make that opportunity a
reality for you what are some of the
resources that you find more valuable
for teaching and for helping others
train yeah because I know we talked
about Hadley Wickham and how his book
has helped with some of the training
that you're working on with the Nairobi
women in machine learning Korean do you
have any ones that particularly to come
to mind that you find very valuable yeah
absolutely I mean there are a couple of
books which we found to be a tremendous
resources in practice the good news is
that they're for free or what it takes
is you know go and click a link and
you'll get them download the PDF print
it and here you're in business
so I say one major book if you're
interested in deep learning is the deep
learning book by a young good fellow
kohrville and benzo that is a fantastic
one and I love to say it's a fantastic
one because it's a real test like it
starts really easy and the difficulty
almost increases exponentially chapter
by chapter so if you're motivated take
the good fellow and make sure you finish
it you'll be a long way into a positive
and successful career in a I'd like to
mention something interesting that
motivates me at instead of in terms of
growing talent so we also have very
experienced researchers working at
institute as well and they somehow
appeared with our junior engineers and
they're able to work together very well
so that really helps our engineers grew
at a really really fast rate in terms of
their skill
yeah that's a common challenge too with
most companies is you know having the
ability to bring in junior talent and
having them be able to grow and the fact
that you're actually mentoring and
setting up that kind of relationship
some companies are doing that not
everybody unfortunately is able to
execute on it they're not doing it
they're not executing on it
and I think you Tony's touching an
important point at
we make sure that all projects as our
cross regional so different teams have
to collaborate nice we've experienced
this in particular with the teams we
have also in Europe we find it to be a
key component everybody gets to the same
access to resources everybody gets to
share and collaborate and we've had
tremendously interesting experiences
with this African talent can pick it up
really quick and we've had cases where
really like the innovation is driven
from Africa and were very proud of that
Hausa so you know we've had for example
research projects and mentioned recent
article which published called rank
rewards which is effectively taking the
work that had been pioneered by deep
mind and David silver in particular
around two player games we found this is
very interesting it's a massive
breakthrough
you know actually technically AI was
invented by Alan Turing to solve chess
so you know you could say alpha zero is
really like a moment in time and we were
very excited by those breakthroughs and
we tried to think about how could this
breakthrough apply to real use cases you
know real businesses real situations
whether it's around transportation or
logistics how to make those useful this
has led us to breakthroughs which were
pioneered in particular by or North
African team which got us to you know
great reviews great feedback and
ultimately building you know next
generation products that will benefit
our team or communities and beyond
that's great so off of that point about
working remotely and you had this great
example in terms of what was being
driven from Africa what are some of the
biggest challenges that you've had
working with remote teams working
together I think it's important to make
sure people communicate and collaborate
so some of the challenges are more like
practical for example when we organize
an off-site make sure you're gonna get
the visas because you know unfortunately
it's very hard to travel around Africa
so problems are practical in nature but
if you are really motivated you could go
beyond them and
create a culture of collaboration so at
instantly people really believe in that
we make sure at least twice a year the
whole global team meets in a location to
exchange and share directly and build up
like an inclusive culture so you know
software is I believe the way to go in
Africa due to some of the difficulties
around moving people moving goods so we
still struggle sometimes with visas and
Moo Tony knows about this you know we
have to fight to get her in at or less
the off-site but in start-up like in
everything else it's about motivation if
you really have the motivation to go
beyond difficulties ultimately in
today's world you can and the point I
want to also make is that you are not
alone if you're an African machine
learning startup you have the chance to
access to tech giants who are there to
help you to develop the ecosystem and I
found that to be really transformational
this also has guided me towards the work
I do with Google as a machine learning
to have expert there are opportunities
out there so don't believe that you're
on your own you're not there are lots of
people who are super excited about the
potential of the continent and will
actually lend a hand and help you that's
been our experience and if we can do the
same and share that feedback and that
positive feedback
I think it's we've gone a long way I see
you nodding with on a anything else you
wanted to add don't you just agree that
it's quite difficult to move our own the
continent but it's interesting to see
the efforts towards just making things
happen because for me representation is
very important and sometimes just this
limits on moving for example we had
colleagues who were to attend a in dhaba
and couldn't get their visas that means
it blocks a part of them accessing
resources and people who would have been
key to the next phase of life but with
technology we are able to bridge some of
these problems and it becomes an easier
way of life I mean I love the fact that
you're talking about particularly how
all of your teams have the same resource
access and that that's what you fight to
achieve but I also very much value the
fact that you're trying to make
that all these teams work together I
mean I've worked with mer mote teams as
well and I feel like I'm stronger when I
work with people who are from different
backgrounds different mindsets and it
sounds like that's a large part of
what's driving this and also what you
experience as well it's you have to
create a culture of inclusiveness and
empowerment all our teams are treated
the same no matter where they are
we value ideas we value intellectual
curiosity so we've had cases where you
know somebody was supposed to work on
something but turned out to be brilliant
and something else we loved that kind of
like positive surprises and if you
create an environment which is positive
which pushes people up and rewards
constant learning intellectual curiosity
you are bound to have good surprises
people's motivation to do things cannot
be overstressed when people have their
own personal motivation to work on
projects then it just makes for example
even the small challenges though of
maybe time because you're working across
different time zones but when you're
motivated to work towards exciting
challenges it makes some of those things
you you easily overlook them I think
yeah thanks well anything else oh we
didn't already cover that you wanted to
touch on that you wanted to emphasize
you know whether it's about incitive
about building communities about deep
learning in Taba I think I mean to
conclude I think it's really an exciting
time for Africa because there is a
transformative technology AI which is
happening and will continue to happen
for the foreseeable future and at the
same time the resources are
progressively there to make taking
opportunities building our businesses
employing people a reality so we're
super excited about this at Institute
and within the deep learning in dava
it's a community of like-minded people
who really sense the opportunity so I
think you know this is a historic
opportunity for Africa and we're super
excited about it and ultimately it's
about building all this together this is
the message of you know deep learning in
dhaba we
together and that will make a difference
so my message to anybody who's listening
is do not believe that you know this is
you know beyond you be part of it
Bottoms Up approach ultimately is the
way to go you know this is what will
change Africa and all what it takes is a
bit of motivation a bit of curiosity and
not being afraid to get started great
things will happen that's wonderful and
actually reminds me of something I heard
you say the other night muthoni was
saying yes saying yes to things that are
also things that feel like they're
impossible or out there beyond you did
you want to add anything else for me my
experience has been that I like to do
personal assessment and some time
earlier this year I realized that I
prefer my comfort zone is lacking in the
shadows and just doing stuff quietly and
silently your own Twitter so when I
refer and recommend at the year vs then
for some reason it had something in my
mind and that is how I ended up for
example accepting to join in studied
because it was a challenge that I
wouldn't have accepted a few months back
or being part of the in depe so yeah I
think I would encourage people to say
yes to opportunities that really really
scare them because sometimes comfort
doesn't grow you as much so yeah and one
last thing we will be a mix very excited
to host a NAPA next year it's another
huge huge challenge but I'm sure it's
going to be a fantastic year so I look
forward to having the India by in Kenya
in 2019 and on my side I mean very
excited about you know the next endeavor
shamsher Moo Tony is gonna be a big part
of organising and also you know maybe
something else I wanted to add is about
a machine learning in Africa I think
this is now is the time to prove to the
world as Africans that we can raise that
even companies out of Africa can be
competitive can stand on their feet and
basically provide the value-added that
we need to make sure our communities and
our economies
are successful in the 21st century
that's what we're trying to do at insta
deep and you know if I had a wish is to
see in the future like successful AI
companies emerging from Africa with the
help and collaboration of you know tech
partners and all people of goodwill but
this is what we haven't seen yet and in
particular instead if that's what
motivates me everyday can we prove as
Africans that we can raise to the
opportunity and build something great
for all the communities and all the
partners we work with cream pathani
thank you very much for coming on the
podcast thank you for having us thanks a
lot thank you thank you again Krim and
muthoni for coming on the podcast and
talking to us about AI corporations
communities instead of all the things we
really appreciate it yeah thanks so much
that was really really interesting mark
question of the week question of the
week if I want to create a gke cluster
with a specific major kubernetes version
or even just the latest using the
command-line tools how do I do that this
is something that I've run into and I
was did you run into the I ran I know I
did I really ran into this right so gke
runs very specific versions of cribben
Nettie's right so for example like 1.10
is available right now so if I'm running
on the gke I might be running one point
ten point six and then usually like
there's a patch release so like - gke
dot six or seven or dot four and those
can roll through pretty quickly you may
be like on one day like you know sort of
like two or three weeks ago you're
running one point ten point six - gke
point one and then you know if you come
back a few weeks later or months later
it might be gke point four and the old
version might not be available anymore
and you might have run scripts either
through the command line or possibly
even deployment manager as well that are
very specific they might be like okay
yes I need this version you know at one
point 10.7 gke - three and that's not
available anymore now suddenly all your
scripts break and it sucks
and I've run into that as well where I
have to update the script every time I
want to create a cluster either with G
cloud or deployment manager but you
don't have to which is super nice
Wow it's amazing it's amazing so the
really nice thing is you can actually
specify a general cluster version so say
for example I want to create a version
just like a 1.10 I'm like I don't care
which like dot version of 1.10 just
create me at one point ten I can
actually say in my initial cluster
version and deployment manager or
cluster dash version in G cloud
basically I can just say equals 110 and
it's just gonna grab the latest 110 if I
want a patch release I can say like one
10.7 and then the lawyers grab the
latest one of that and you know at the
desk UK on the end or if I just want the
latest I can just write latest ok yeah
so it'll just work it out for you behind
the scenes they can save you a lot of
time make your scripts a little less
brittle I make things a little bit
easier for you we like easy yep cool
mark where you gonna be I will be at Q
Khan in December but other than that
doing some vacation next month
yeah vacation you I will be it so kamal
at the end of november and that's the
main plan cool that sounds good
yeah so real quick before we wrap
absolutely I want to just do a quick
little PSA if you are in the u.s. please
vote yes we're not gonna sit here and
tell you who to vote for I've got my own
opinions but you can check out my
Twitter feed if you want to know my
opinions but yeah please vote if you
were thinking about if you're on the
fence whatever please definitely vote
this midterm election awesome well
Melanie thank you so much for that and
thank you for joining me for you again
on this week's podcast thank you Mark
and thank you all for listening and
we'll see you all next week
[Music]